[Musique]
on entend beaucoup de choses négatives
sur la politique de la ville qu'elle
coûte un fric de dingue et qu'elle ne
sert à rien que la mixtité sociale est
une utopie qu'on ne n'atteindra jamais
que le véritable problème de la France
c'est pas celui des banlieux mais celui
de la France périphérique comme l'a
montré le le mouvement des gilets jaunes
alors pour en savoir un peu plus pour
comprendre un peu les choses je suis
allé trouver Renaud Stein Renaud Stein
est professeur de sociologie à sciencep
Saint-Germain c'est l'un des grands
spécialistes de la politique de la ville
quand et pourquoi est née cette
politique de la ville quelles sont ses
réussites et quels sont ses échecs quel
est aussi son son devenir voilà
quelques-unes des questions que je lui
ai posé écoutez ses
réponses
il y a deux dates possibles ou bien on
dit c'est début des années 70 dès 71
quand Albain Chalandon ministre de
l'équipement à l'époque créé un groupe
de haut fonctionnaires qui s'appelle
groupe habitat et vie sociale des
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'équipement du ministère de la Jeunesse
du secrétariat d'État la jeunesse et des
affaires sociales qui travaillent
ensemble pour se poser des questions sur
les conditions de la vie social dans ces
quartiers des grands ensembles qui
étaient alors en train encore de sortir
de de terre moi il me semble que c'est
plus juste de faire dat de faire
commencer cette politique en 81 82 à la
suite d'meutes sauf qu'à l'époque on
appppelait pas ça des émeutes le terme
qui avait été qui s'était imposé
médiatiquement pendant l'été 81 c'était
le terme de rodéo des Minguettes hein
donc dans les Minguettes quartier de
l'Est lyonnais de de V de véicieux où
bon il y a ce qu'on appellerait
aujourd'hui des
émeutes et à la suite de cet événement
qui a qui a marqué l'actualité début des
années 80 la gauche n'est d'arrivé au
pouv pou voir et dans les mois qui
suivent dans les semaines qui suivent il
y a ces événements qui qui ont un
retentissement national et qui mettent à
l'épreuve le gouvernement de Pierre
maois he sur Moe pour caricaturer la
gauche arrive au pouvoir c'est la
chiandie oui c'est ça donc faut pas
maintenir l'ordre VO voilà et donc il y
a il y a le gouvernement de de Pierre
Marois se saisit de la question et va
notamment instituer une Commission
Nationale pour le Développement Social
des Quartiers présidé par le le maire de
grenov ubert du Bedou l'époque et cette
commission va mettre en place une
première politique une procédure qu'on
va appeler les politiques de
développement social des quartiers pour
aller très vite c'est des contrats qui
sont signés par l'État avec les villes
au terme de ces contrats l'État accorde
un budget qui peut être utilisé de façon
totalement souple par les ville pour
soutenir tout types d'initiatives
développées notamment par les
associations de quartier en matière
d'action sociale culturelle sportive
d'animation éducative dans tous les
domaines pour répondre aux
problématiques qui se manifeste dans ces
quartiers de grands ensembles popéris
les grands moments de de de de
développement ou de recomposition de
cette politique sont en réponse à à des
émeutes notamment alors il y a eu celle
les rodéo des Minguettes début 80elin il
y a eu V envelin fin 89 euh et quelques
mois après donc euh ces ces émeutes
alors qu'on d'autant plus marqué que
elles ont eu lieu dans le quartier du
mat du Tureau à vaau envelin qui était
le quartier modèle du du DSQ du
Développement Social des Quartiers quand
on faisait venir des délégations
étrangères qu'on V leur montrraer voilà
ce qu'on fait nous en France quartier on
les amenait à vvelin et justement ce
quartier qui était le quartier modèle
devient le quartier qui suite à une la
mort d'un jeune pour en moto pour suivi
par la police sans bras scénario qui
s'est répété depuis de la multip reprise
euh voilà donc c'est un peu de perçu
comme le symbole de l'échec de des et
quelques semaines après François
mitteran intervient à dans un colloque à
Bron à quelques kilomètres de là où il
prononce son discours sur la politique
je dis son discours parce que c'est le
seul qui a prononcé sur ces 14 ans de
mandat sur la politique de la ville et
un discours assez marquant dans lequel
il dit en gros bon depuis 81 82 il y a
plein de quartiers il y a du
Développement social il y a plein
d'initiatives des travailleurs sociaux
des des associations des éducateurs des
policiers tout le monde essaie de faire
des choses bien et c'est très bien ce
que vous fait mais mais ça a pas
l'ampleur c'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux et face à l'exclusion qui c'est
le terme qui s'impose à la fin des
années 80 face à l'exclusion
socio-spaciale c'est pas plein de
petites initiatives par le bas qui vont
changer la donne il faut que ça passe
par une mobilisation du sommet de l'État
il faut une politique massive qui prenne
qui dit très
clairement le mon gouvernement ve quoi
gouverement Michel Rocard va faire de
cette question de l'exclusion
sociopatiale sa priorité moi j'en fais
la priorité de mon de mon 2è SEP et donc
et ça c'est ça devient d'un seul coup ce
quiétait une politique plutôt bricolée
par le bas dans les qutive avec les
associations devient une politique par
le haut et c'est pas qu'un discours
suite à ça ben il y a le premier
ministre de la V voà app le ministère de
la Ville ça voilà avec un ministre qui
est nommé qui est Michel
delbarid du Nord enfin de la France
voilà maire de der qui par tout à fait
et symboliquement c'est extrêmement
important il est nommé ministre de la
Ville mais il est nommé ministre d'État
ou et numéro 3 du gouvernement alors
j'insiste là-dessus parce que
symboliquement c'est important mais
c'est pas que symbolique il y a un poids
politique qui accordé à la politique de
la ville qui s'est jamais retrouvé par
la suite si ce n'est un peu avec
Bartolone et avec
borl
parmi les les éléments qui caractérisent
la politique par rapport à d'autres
politiques il y a d'abord le fait que
c'est une politique qui a la prétention
d'être globale c'est-à-dire que c'est
pas une politique qui va s'occuper de la
jeunesse qui va s'occuper du logement
qui va s'occuper de la santé qui va
s'occuper de elle doit s'occuper de tout
à côté de toutes les autres politiques
qui découpent la société en secteur
précis la politique de la ville elle
cherche à traiter des relations qui
entre tout ça avec l'idée que si vous
avez des jeunes qui sont en difficulté
qui sont en galère si vous traitez leurs
problèmes de logement mais vous traitez
pas leurs problème d'insertion
économique vous résolez pas le problème
si vous traitez leur par la formation
mais que vous prenez pas en charge leurs
problème de santé de dentaire ou je sais
pas quoi donc il faut essayer
d'articuler tout tout pour pour résoudre
les
problèmes la création alors ce qui a été
à l'origine en
1990 de de la délégation intern
ministérielle à ville qui a depuis à
changé de nom qui s'est transformé que
aujourd'hui c'est l'Agence nationale
pour la cohésion des territoire euh elle
a toujours hésité cette administration
entre dire bah en fait moi j'ai mon
objet c'est les quartiers c'est moi qui
m'en occupe j'ai mes programmes et une
autre approche qui consiste à dire moi
administration j'ai pas d'argent la
politique de la ville son budget c'est 1
dem% du budget de l'État pour des
quartiers qui représentent en gros 8 à
10 % de la population beaucoup d'argent
faut relativiser on renir mais vous
verrez et et donc est-ce que la
politique de la ville elle est là avec
ses programmes pour résoudre les
problèmes des quartiers ou bien est-ce
que elle est là pour aider toutes les
autres politiques publiques toutes les
autres institutions de l'État mais aussi
les collectivités à mieux travailler
mieux analyser mieux répondre au
problèmes des des quartiers et ça c'est
une sorte de tension qui a traversé
cette politique pendant 40 ans avec des
des fluctuations maintenant sur le point
d'un point de vue thématique il y a eu
aussi des évolutions par exemple je vous
ai dit c'est une politique globale oui
mais très clairement depuis 2003 et la
loi borlau et le lancement du programme
national de rénovation urbaine oui la
rénovation urbaine est au cœur des
choses he bah oui c'est c'est devenu et
alors même si ça l'IT moins ces
dernières années mais c'est devenu le
cœur de la politique de la ville ne
serait-ce que budgétairement vous avez
un programme le PNRU programme national
de rénovation
urbaine depuis 2003 c'est à peu près 50
milliards de EUR d'investissement euh la
politique de la ville euh son budget
total si je me souviens bien là
actuellement dans le budget de l'État on
est à 500 ou 550 millions oui donc ça
vous donne un peu la proportion et donc
vous voyez bien que d'un seul coup il y
a et alors ça ça vaut pour le budget de
l'État mais ça vaut localement quand
vous avez des projets de rénovation
urbaine des projets de démolition
reconstruction de quartier qui pour
certains engagent des sommes colossales
hein je crois que le plus gros ça clichi
Montfermeil on est à un demi mililliard
d'euros 500 millions d'euros sur une
vingtaine d'années hein d'investir pour
complètement démolir et reconstruire un
quartier nan si on est au même ordre de
grandeur mante la jolie on est je pas
les chiffres en tête mais on est à plus
de 100 millions faut dire que pardon
mais c'est c'est vrai que il y a eu un
moment où il y avait besoin de main
d'œuvre pour l'industrie on a construit
vite fait des des des bâtiments euh
c'était ça un peu hein aussi les
quartiers et à un moment c'est vrai que
ça ça enfin ça ne fonctionnait plus vous
avez été mal conçu ou conçu pour dans
des sortes d'utopie qui ne marchaient
pas euh et donc oui la reconstruction
elle s'imposait d'une certaine façon non
alors alors d'abord d'abord sur Av il y
avait besoin de loger de loger quoi
pendant les années les années postsee
guerre mondiale P les années 50 il y
avait besoin de loger mais pas
simplement loger sur l'image je sais pas
moi de poissie on a les grosses usines
automobiles il faut des bataillons
de oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que ce n'était pas que ça c'estàdire que
il faut quand même souvenir l'état de la
crise du logement euh
con tout le compris lesassyen supéure de
la bouroisie après un siècle pendant
lequel on n pas construit en France et
après de guerres qui ont produit des
dommages de dans sur le le
patmine de reconstruction de et qui se
limitait pas à loger les ouvriers des
usines r ça que je veux dire et qui
concnait pas que les grandes villes
industrielles parce qu'on on a souvent
tendance à penser politique de la ville
bon en gros l'île-defance la scène
saintis un peu SC naal et lyonnais ou
Marseille Nord mais quand vous vous
baladez partout en France n'importe
quelle ville moyenne contre aussi son
son petit grand ensemble voir son gros
grand ensemble grands ensemble
et donc il s'agissait de répondre à une
crise du logement qui était massive et
de ce point de vue-là la politique de
reconstruction planifiée des grands
ensembles a largement contribué à
résoudre la crise du logement et au-delà
d'ailleurs de la résolution de crise du
logement a transformé l'appareil de
production de du logement en France euh
donc ça ça a vraiment joué un rôle qui a
été déterminant dans dans la la
modernisation de la France des années de
reconstruction et dans les dynamique de
promotion sociale d'élévation de la
société française dans dans dans la
dynamique des 30ente glorieuses euh bon
depuis les années
80 chômage de masse euh
qui promotion de la du logement
individuel du pavillon qui ont fait que
il y a eu des mécanismes de de fuite
sélective de C quti qui étaiit des
quartiers sinon de mixité mais dans
lequel il y avait quand même une assez
grande diversité de population jusqu'au
la fin des années 70 qui progressivement
ont vu l'éclat les classes moyennes
partirent pour l'accession à la
propriété l'élite de la classe ouvrière
partir et progressivement ces quartiers
se spécialisaient d'un point de vue
social mais aussi d'un point de vue
ethnooracial il faut quand même voir
qu'à partir de 1977 il y a une réforme
des politiques du logement ce qu'on
appelle la réforme bar qui et que l'État
a à partir de 77 une politique de qui a
soutenu très fortement l'accession à la
propriété individuelle et donc c'est pas
les gens ont fu c'est aussi que on a été
incité fiscalement à le faire donc ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est il faut toujours faire
attention à dans la généralisation qu'on
fait et que je fais moi aussi depuis le
début de notre discussion c'est on parle
des quartiers mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de commun
entre entre le valfouré à Man la jolie
et le quartier malakov à Nantes qui
quasiment dans l'hypercentre de Nant
cent
àonilleri
décl et et le Sanita Satour qui qui est
ce sont des quartiers qui ont en commun
une forme
urbaine souvent une même même type de
logement sont des logements massivement
HM mais pas toujours regardez greini ou
le problème de greini 2 ou le problème
de du chaîne pointue à clichi qui sont
les quartiers les plus dégradés de
France c'est que justement c'est pas des
HLM c'est des des
copropriétés vrai c'est beaucoup et et
les HLM bon des boîtes HLM elles savent
gérer leur patrimoine elles le font plus
ou moins bien mais une copropriété
dégradée la moitié des logements on été
acheté par les marchands de sommeil ou
la famille les familles ont plus
personne va investir voilà c'est c'est
encore plus compliqué donc tout ça pour
vous dire que derrière ces quartiers il
y a quand même des différences entre des
quartiers encore une fois qui sont des
quartiers dans des métropoles dynamiques
et d'un des quartiers dans des petites
villes en déclin on n'est pas les mêmes
populations je sais pas moi j'avais
travaillé il yel quelques années à
moulin dans
l'Allier la problématique centrale de de
pour le le quartier prioritaire le
quartier plus difficile de moulin c'est
la question de l'adaptation au
vieillissement on est dans les quartiers
bon les jeunes s'en vont parce que il y
a plus beaucoup de boulot dans l'Allier
à Moulin il que la population qui était
là ouvrière elle elle bouge pas ben le
problème c'est c'est c'est que comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour des bâtiments qui
ont pas été qui ont été pensés pour des
pour des familles et qui compte
aujourd'hui une bonne partie de
population du 3e du 4e image c'est pas
les mêmes problématiques que quand on
est dans des quartiers très jeunes comme
les quartiers de sa saintis et cetera
donc oui oui il y a une diversité une
diversité de problématique ce qui est en
tout cas clair c'est que depuis
2003 l'État mais pas que l'État l'État
les villes les bailleurs sociaux ont
donné une priorité dans le casadre de
cette politique à la transformation
urbaine he à l'action sur le cadre bâti
l'aménagement l'offre de logement à
travers le programme national
deinnovation urbaine plus de milliards
ont été investis je vous le disais alors
je dis 50 milliards on a l'impression
qu'on met beaucoup d'argent faut bien
voir que ces 50 milliards c'est pas de
l'argent de l'État alors c'est il y a 12
milliards d'euros de subvention de
l'Agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
mais sur ces 12 milliards les 3/4
proviennent du 1 % logement c'est-à-dire
des contributions des des entreprises
pour loger leurs salariés et localement
le premier premier contributeur ce sont
les bailleurs sociaux les H&M donc c'est
avec les loyers
des gens qui habitent dans C quartiers
donc quand on dit 50 milliards on a
l'impression on met des milliards non ce
sont les employeurs pour loger leurs
salariés et les HLM avec les les loyers
de leur locataire
voilà ce qui est très clair c'est que la
rénovation
urbaine a transformé les quartiers du
point de vue de d'un point de vue de
leur organisation
physique je dis ça ça peut sembler une
évidence on met de l'argent ça marche
mais vous savez des des des politiques
publiques sont annoncé on nous dit on va
mettre tant de milliards pour faire ça
et ça ne se fait pas parce que les
décrets d'application sont pas sortis
parce que c'est trop compliqué parce que
les acteurs s'en sont pas saisis c'est
c'est plus la la la règle que
l'exception ouis euh la rénovation
urbaine et d'une certaine façon le c'est
très long c'est long ça prend du temps
de construire de transformer la ville
mais ça s'est mis en œuvre ça s'est mis
en œuvre et
aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous balader
dans à peu près 500 quartiers en France
c'est très clairement il y a des
investissements massifs qui ont été
faits il y a des tours qui sont tombé il
y a des bars qui ont été d'immeubles qui
ont été coupés il y a des nouvelles
constructions qui ont été qui ont été
faites il y a des équipements scolaires
socio culturels qui ont été rénovés les
espaces publics qui ont été rénovés tout
ça après 30 ans ou 40 ans pendant
lesquels l'État les collectivités les
bailleurs sociaux avaient quasiment
cessé d'investir dans ces quartiers h
oui il les avaent laissé à l'abandon
c'est peut-être un peu excessif mais en
tout cas il y avait pas eu
d'investissement et euh bah vous voyez
ça ça vaut pour ces quartiers comme pour
n'importe quel espace dans la ville le
cadre bâti ça vieillit si on ninvestisse
pas en continu ça se dégrade des
dégradations voilà qui voà et et donc
donc il y a eu cette transformation elle
est visible maintenant quand on regarde
la la la la le programme de de borlau il
visait pas à faire de la transformation
urbaine pour la transformation urbaine
c'était pas on va faire juste des jolis
quartiers l'idée c'est on transforme la
forme de ces quartiers l'urbanisme de
ces quartiers pour en transformer la
population avec l'idée qu'on va produire
de la mixité sociale qui va résoudre les
problèmes sociaux il cette idée qu'on
retrouve souvent quand on parle avec les
les ma notamment c'est de de donner une
sort de fierté aux habitants d'habiter
leur quartier alors ça c'est une
deuxième dimension je non non mais vous
avez raison de le rappeler parce que ça
ça n'apparaissait pas dans les
objectifsinition je dire quand borlau
défend sa loi c'est vraiment mixité
sociale mixité sociale ou c'est dire
attirer une autre population qui
n'aurait pas été dans ces quartiers
parce que ils sont plus jolis il sont
ils sont plus plus agréables à vivre et
CER c'est ça tout à fait tout à fait
avec l'idée que si on fait coexister
dans un même espace des populations
diversifié bah ça va résoudre toute une
série de problèmes et ça marche ça alors
il y a deux questions derrière d'abord
c'est votre question moi je peux
répondre de deux façons c'est est-ce que
d' point du théorique est-ce que la
mixité la réponse à plein d'autres
problèmes sociaux ça c'est une première
question qu'on peut discuter et il y a
une deuxième question c'est est-ce que
la transformation des quartiers tel
qu'elle a eu lieu a permis de changer la
population voàexcité alors donc si on
prend les deux questions un on a bien
investi 50 milliards on a transformé les
quartiers des quartiers qui pour
certains étaient tellement dégradés des
des conditions d'habitat indignes euh et
effectivement ça c'est je trouve que
c'est la la moindre des choses d'offrir
à des gens qui payent leurs loyers et
qui vivent dans les mêmes ville des
conditions de vie décentes un cadre de
vie décent et de ce point de vue-là la
rénovation urbaine ensuite elle a été
plus ou moins réussie suiv qutiers
suivant les opérations mais globalement
elle s'est mis en place ça amélioré le
cadre de vie d'accord voilà est-ce que
ça s'est prolongé par un renouvellement
de la populationulation la réponse est
non très clairement non on a mis du
temps à faire des évaluations à bien
suivre à comparer des quartiers qui
avaient bénéficié de la rénovation
urbaine d'autres qui avaient pas
bénéficié de la rénovation urbaine pour
voir si la population les dynam et et la
réalité c'est que en fait la rénovation
urbaine n'a pas changé les quartiers
populaires rest reste des quartiers
populaires et des quartiers souvent très
populaires euh est-ce que c'est un
problème ça c'est ça m'amène à la
deuxième question euh sur la mixité
est-ce que finalementou est c'est la
réponse est-ce que pour une personne qui
est euh pauvre est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
habiter dans un quartier pauvre ou dans
un quartier riche euh ou dans dans un
quartier mixte est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
que ses voisins soient dans des
conditions TR alors ça c'est une
question qui est hyper débat et ça fait
à peu près euh 75 ans que euh partout
dans le monde des géographes des
sociologues des urbanistes des des
politistes des psychologues et se Pench
sur la question il y a des études dans
tous les sens j'ai un collègue anglais
qui a dénombré plus de 1500 études
cherchant à répondre à cette question à
cette question et on n'a pas de bah en
fait sur cette question on n'a pas
directement de réponse définitive
euh il y a des avantages quand on est
pauvre habiter dans un quartier pauvre
après il y a pardon allez-y allez-y mais
il y a il y a le danger de ça et c'est
ce qu'on parle parfois de quartiers
oubliés de la République de quartier
voilà où les des communautés au près le
pouvoir enfin en dehors même des lois de
la République enfin c'est ce qu'on dit
d' un certain nbre de quartiers c'est un
des dangers de ça si si on est si on
reste dans une population qui se
ressemble oui alors en même temps bon ce
que dire ce que montre tous les travaux
alors là il y a vraiment des consensus
ce que TR les travaux notamment dans le
cas français mais ça vaut plus
généralement mais c'est très marqué dans
le cas français c'est qu'il y a des
vrais ghos c'est des vrais quartiers
dans lequels on ne fait que tous ces
voisins nous ressemblent ces quartiers
sont les quartiers
riches les quartiers dans lequel il y a
la plus grande homogénéité sociale
plutôt les qu c'est les quarti rich euh
ça c'est un premier point et que si on
voulait provocateur on pourrait dire que
ceux qui font ces session de la
République c'est pas les pauvres qui
choisissent pas d'habiter avec des
pauvres c'est plutôt les riches qui
choisissent d'habiter entre rich ça
c'est un premier point deuxème deuxème
point c'est est-ce que est-ce que ces
quartiers maintenant si je parle des
quartiers de la politique de la ville
euh est-ce que pour une personne donnée
habiter dans ce quartier ou en sortir
pour aller dans cé mixte est-ce que ça
change le le destin individuel est-ce
qu'il vous euh là on a des résultats
d'études qui sont très contradictoire
très euh mais il y a en revanche un
point sur lequel il y a un consensus
international national sur les vertus de
la mixité c'est pas dans l'espace
résidentiel est-ce qu'on habite dans un
endroit où autour de ses voisins nous
ressemble nous ressemble pas qu'est-ce
que ça change c'est très mais il y a un
espace sur lequel les vertus de la
mixité sont prouvées c'est l'espace
scolaire ouais c'est-à-dire que euh à
l'échelle de l'école et plus encore à
l'échelle de la classe de la classe
avoir euh des pauvres et des riches ou
des gamins qui ont les ressources
culturelles chez eux pour se faire aider
pour réussir scolairement et d'autres
qui les ont moins cette mixité ça tire
vers le haut les gamins qui ont le moins
de ressources et ça ne plombe pas la
tête de classe d'accord et ah oui non ça
c'est vraiment parce que souvent on
entend dire ça en tout cas Mo si j'en
crois tous mes collègues qui travaillent
vraiment sur les questions scolaires ça
ne plombe pas et en revanche ça a une
vertu pour tout le monde si je devais
prendre des grands termes
d'apprentissage du vivre ensemble
d'apaisement des tensions sociales à
l'échelle de la classe à l'échelle de la
cour de récré et à l'échelle de la
société et c'est de ce point de vue là
si on a envie de dire si on veut se
battre pour la la cohésion et il faut se
battre sur la mixité dans l'espace
scolaire plus que dans l'espace
résidentiel or les deux on pourrait se
dire bah si on a des quti mixte on aura
des écoles mixtes en réalité c'est pas
le cas les gens mettent les en VO les
vides dans privé ou des choses comme ça
donc voilà sur la mixité après il faut
une sorte de dosage je suppose non parce
que je dire si vous êes c'est vrai qu'il
y a des il a il y a des écoles où il y a
euh plusieurs plusieurs élèves qui qui
sont de de de nationalités assez
différentes qui parlent pas forcément
très bien français et cetera si vous
avez trop ensemble ou non mais c'est
c'est pour ça la mixité scolaire est un
vrai en c'est vraiment un enjeu mais il
est à l'échelle de l'école à l'échelle à
l'échelle de la classe et si on veut
vraiment on pense que on a une société
qui devient de plus en plus fragmentée
que ça que ça devent un risque ne nous
trompons pas de cible le levier majeur
principal c'est l'école et l'enjeu mixé
à l'échelle de l'école notamment ces
cités éducatives qui ont été qui ont été
fondé qui qui marche plutôt pas trop mal
c'est ça fait partie de ces programmes
développés dans le cadre de la politique
de la ville depuis un peu moins 10 ans
là les cités éducatives euh alors les
cités éducatives sont intéressantes il y
a des évaluations qui montrent que dans
un grand nombre de cas ça produit
vraiment des dynamiques très positiv
mais ça ne joue pas véritablement sur la
mixité euh ça joue sur le la façon dont
l'élève est est considéré pris en charge
pris en charge et surtout sur les
relations entre l'école et son
environnement euh avec parce qu'on a
c'est vrai historiquement une éducation
nationale qui est plutôt refermée sur
elle-même et qui laisse de place aux
parents qui s'app a du mal à s'appuyer
avec les les à s'articuler avec les
associations qui font du sport du
soutien scolaire en dehors de la classe
les cités éducatives permettent
d'organiser un peu de d'ouvrir les
portes de l'école et de d'organiser
cette continuité éducative entre les
familles les associations les villes et
l'école et ma foi c'est plutôt
intéressant mais ça change pas Grand-
chose sur la mixité en revanche mais
d'accord oui oui bien sûr la politique
de la ville tout à l'heure vous
demandiez comment la définir j'aurais pu
la définir autrement vous dis
c'est une politique de excusez-moi
jeutilis des mots des gros mots de
discrimination positive territoriale
c'està-dire c'est une politique qui est
supposer organiser le fait qu'on on
donne plus aux territoires qui ont moins
ou qui concentrre les difficultés et
cette discrimination positive
territorial les les maires la reformule
souvent justement donner plus c'est pas
nécessement plus d'argent mais c'est
donner plus de servicees public pour des
quartiers qui consentent les populations
qui ont besoin de particulièrement
besoin DEES services publics et
simplement quand je dit la politique de
VI est une politique de discrimination
positive territoriale c'est un
mensonge elle prétend l'être cherche à
l' mais elle n pas vraiment c'estàdire
que la politique de la ville y a quand
même des zones franches y a des budget
si je prends tous les dispositifs l'état
consacre chaque année si je prends le
projet de loi de finan là ou 550 ou 600
là maintenant 600 millions d'euros pour
ces quartiers 600 millions d'euros c'est
quand même une somme
conséquente bon mais 600 million d'euros
c'est moins d'un demi% du budget de
l'État pour des quartiers qu'and
qu'and 10 % voilà la question c'est si
ces quartiers bénéficient aussi donc
mettons je simplifie les choses
politique de la ville 1 % du budget de
l'État autre politique 99 %. si ces
autres politiques traitent de façon
égalitaire les territoires si tel ou tel
quartier sont bien
couvert% bah le le demi% de politique d'
ville peut vraiment faire plus mais sauf
que la réalité elle est autre
l'éducation nationale les politiques de
l'emploi tous les grandes politiques en
fait traitent de façon inégale les
territoires et les quartiers visés par
la politique de la ville sont
particulièrement maltraités excusez-moi
pour le mot budgetairement maltraité ce
qui fait que le petit plus qu'on accorde
au titre de la politique de la ville ne
vient pas compenser le gros moins qui
est lié au fonctionnement ordinaire des
services publics moi je prends toujours
un même exemple pour pour illustrer ce
propos l'éducation nationale a depuis
1983 une politique de ZEP de zone
d'éducation prioritaire qu'elle change
de nom mais bon voilàéducation
prioritaire qui consiste accorder des
moyens supplémentaires pour les
établissements scolaires qui accueillent
les populations les plus en difficulté
c'est un programme qui est coûteux pour
l'éducation nationale puisque en moyenne
être en Z pour une école ça veut dire
avoir deux enfants en moins par classe
si on ve avoir deux enfants en moins par
classe bah faut mettre plus de profs
c'est mécanique plus de profs bah c'est
plus de salaire donc ça coûte de
l'argent sauf que sauf que qui sont les
profs qui sont qui enseignent en ZEP des
profs sortis d'école les plus jeunes
débutants qui
ont au mieux le CAPS mais maintenant qui
sont de plus en plus souvent recrutés
par en compte sur contrat et cetera qui
sont les profs qui vont enseigner dans
d'autres territoires soit ruraux ou en
centrre-ville des agrégés des profs plus
âgés qui on de l'exérienceexérience et
ça veut dire donc des profs qui coûtent
beaucoup plus cher en terme de salaire
et donc on a beau donner des des crédits
spécifiques au titre de l'éducation
prioritaire pour ces lycées au
final le coût budgétaire d'un
enfant un enfant de prolo est nettement
inférieur pour la pour l'État que le
coût d'un enfant de Bourjois d'accord
très nettement d'ailleurs c'est c'est
intéressant parce que la discrimination
positive je lisais une phrase des maires
mais c'est une demande au fond de
discrimination politique pu si nous
pouvons accepter que perdure des
inégalités flagrantes des
discriminations et une certaine
stigmatisation c'est un peu ça c'est un
peuaeler à alors alors c'est ce qui
rappelle là c'est d'abord ça c'est cette
inégalité de traitement puis rajoute une
dimension qui me semble aussi une
dimension importante alors il y a la
stigmatisation qui renvoie et qui
renvoie bah à vous quoi pas vous
personnellement mais aussi les médias et
la représentation qu'on construit aussi
de ces qu pour parler ou ce a encore une
autre dimension et puis il y a la notion
de discrimination c'estàd que la notion
de discrimination je pense qu'elle prend
un elle raisonne tout particulièrement
dans ces quartiers même si elle se
limite pas il parle de discrimination
négative oui oui alors en même temps
quand il parle dans le regard tout à
fait mais il renvoie aussi à je pense
hein ses Maes à la notion de
discrimination
ethnoraciale c'est-à-dire aux inégalités
de traitement de population fondés sur
des critères d'une origine réelle ou
supposée or ces quartiers sont des
quartiers qui concentrent tout
particulièrement les populations
immigrées descendants de l'immigration
mais aussi les domiens euh qui sont conf
confonté à des discriminations qui sont
lié beaucoup plus massivement à leur
apparence qu'à leur
adresse et et la question le contrôle
policier et C oui ou dans dans l'emploi
dans dans la formation dans dans l'accès
au logement voilà on a toute une série
de testes qui nous montrent
que des expériences et il y a eu des
expériences de deux sortes d'abord pour
mesurer ces discrimination qu' on révél
l'intensité
h pe àendre mesure en tout cas comme
vous et moi on est blanc je crois que
quand on est pas blanc on prend bien la
mesure de ce que peut être la
discrimination et puis il y a eu des
tentatives de mise en place d'outils de
lutte contre la discrimination mais qui
en on
été très limité la seule qui a été un
peu politique un peu instituée ça a été
à la suite des émeutes de 2005 Dominique
de Villepin avait adopté cette loi qui
s'appelait égalité des chances de
mémoire dans lequel on expérimentait le
CV anonyme et finalement ça pas ça a été
abandonné ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui en
France par comparaison à d'autres pays
les politiques de lutte contre
discrimination se limite à à quoi bah de
la sensibilisation mais oui contour
d'ailleurs les témoignages des des gens
qui jeunes qui vivent dans ces quartier
la difficulté de trouver un emploi est
quelque chose de compliqué quoi bah
c'est c'est la difficulté de trouver un
emploi les rapports très très compliqué
avec la police nationale oui oui sont
des questions qui reviennent de façon
récurrente quand on écoute les jeunes
mais pas que les jeunes nous venons de
voir avec rodstein l'histoire de la
politique de la ville comment et
pourquoi elle est née comment elle s'est
développée bien maintenant nous allons
aborder son actualité qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé depuis l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron en
2017 j'ai envie de dire moi aujourd'hui
de parler du rendez-vous manqué de
d'Emmanuel Macron et des banlieux parce
que quand il se fait et lire plutôt
quand il fait campagne en
2017 il fait campagne avec des discours
qu'on avait jamais entendu en France ou
très rarement extrêmement libéraux et
quand je dis libéraux c'est dans en sens
de philosophie politique pas simplement
libéral politique économiquement mais
aussi très libéral discours très
libéraux sur la laïcité sur les
discriminations pendant sa campagne 2017
il parle de violence policière de
discrimination policière il il dit mais
vois pas pourquoi on emmerde les femmes
qui mettent un voile il il parle en
direction des des quartiers il dit oui
il a un rapport d'ailleurs assez
particulier à la licité enfin év évolué
depu au départ
d'ailleurs les les les tenant de la
léicité le regardz un peu avec tout à
fait et et il a un discours aussi qui
est extrêmement ouvert sur sur la
bonlieue sur le mode justement mais la
Bonlieu arrêtons de de de de la peindre
en noir regardons toutes les énergies
toutes les forces qu'il y a dans ces
quartiers discours très valorisant et on
pouvait s'attendre donc et à ce qu'il
ait une politique très active en
direction de de de ce quartier qui
incarne dans son discours toujours en
2017 d'une certaine façon les enjeux de
l'égalité des chances hein or à peine
élu gouverne donc Édouard Philippe prer
ministre l'été 2017 c'est l'été l'été
noir pour l'été meurtrier pour la
politique de la ville en 3 semaines on
coupe on coupe dans les crédits de la
politique de la ville on coupe dans les
budgets des emplois aid orors les
associations de quartier tournent
énormément sur les employid et on coupe
dans les budgets des HLM avec les dans
les APL comp pens c'est 1 milliard par
an dans les budgets deshlm ce qui pour s
donc là il y a une sorte de stupeur de
la part des élus ce qui va susciter
l'appel de greini transpartisan pour
pour les quartiers Emmanuel Macron qui
répond en disant bah je vais confier une
mission à Jean-Louis borlau pour penser
l'avenir de la politique de la ville et
puis cet événement très traumatique pour
tous les élus de la politique de la
ville TR B V ah bah oui de la remise du
rapport borlot de sa réception et de
d'une forme d'humiliation organisée par
Emmanuel Macron non seulement de
Jean-Louis borlau mais de tous les
maires qui étaient présents puisque
quand même si vous reprenez oui c'est ça
c'est pas par vous que ça va ça va
marcher quoi c'est même pire que ça
c'est dit finalement la politique de la
ville est telle que vous la faites c'est
un peu du clientélisme et ça vous
arrange bien et c'est d' C façon il dit
au maire s'il y a de la si c'est la
merde dans V les quartiers c'est c'est
pour vous et parce que vous faites la
vieille politique et et moi je vais je
vais changer tout ça traumatisme
traumatisme pour les élus il y a ça il y
a quand même des maires qui se sont
levés pendant le discours du président
dans la salle des fêtes de l'Élysée et
qui sont sortis pendant le discours je
suis pas sûr que ce soit arrivé souvent
dans l'histoire de la 5e République et
des républiques précédentes non un vrai
traumatisme et alors suite à ça et suite
quand même n de de de conseiller deproch
Emmanuel Macron que peut-être là il a
été un peu loin on n'entend plus parler
de la politique de la ville pendant le
reste du septena du quinquena
excusez-moi on en entend parler juste au
moment de
la loi alors comment elle s'appelait
séparatisme et égalité des chances je
sais plus son titre exact oui quand il
vient au Mureau exactement discours des
Mureaux où dit bon voilà séparatiste
mais en même temps donc mais égalité des
chances et puis Jean Castex son premier
ministre qui ensuite va faire un CIV là
à
greini et puis je pense que bon mais il
y a des annonces sans sans trop de suite
ça arrive pendant le au moment du
deuxème confinement
et tout ça tombe un peu à l'eau et on
entend plus parler euh arrive le deuxè
quinena et
euh on arrive là en juin
2023 et l'Élysée Matignon
organise prévoit ce qu'ils appellent une
séquence banlieu qui devait permettre un
peu de faire le reset voilà on a raté le
premier le rendez-vous dans premier on
va tout REM à on va faire le grand truc
et donc il y a un truc un vrai plan de
com qui est organisé qui est super le
lundi Emmanuel Macron est à Marseille
Marseille en grand l'ouverture des
écoles plein de trucs et cetera une
rencontre avec 5h de débat dans le
gymnase de la buisine buserine avec des
habitants du quartier il retrouve un peu
ce truc grand débat gilets jaunes et
tout ça qui est venu après une séquence
retraite qui fait que pendant à peu près
un an c'était difficile pour d'aller au
contact et
voilà de ça montre le président qui
revient et le lendemain il y avait le
lancement de l'anniversaire de lanrue
des 20 ans de lanrue et donc à grriininy
le matin Jean-Louis borelot Olivier clin
ministre de la Ville Catherine
arenou tout le monde est là et on on
lance un programme qui a été bien pensé
par l' rue qui devait mettre en scène ce
qui a été fait depuis 20 ans pour
transformer les quartiers c'est vrai que
on a des images qui sont produites il y
a vraiment tout ce programme qui vise à
montrer que oui on nous dit les Mair
nous disent on fait mais en fait en
réalité on fait et puis tout ça devait
se terminer le jeudi ou le vendredi je
sais plus par un comité interministériel
des villes qui allait dans lequel le
gouvernement allait annoncer sa
politique pour les 5 ans à venir comité
interministérial des villes qui avait
déjà été reporté trois fois deux fois
pardon
précédemment et ça fait quand même 2 ans
que la politique d'aville a plus
d'orientation nationale et donc tout ça
vraiment tout ça devitre centré sur une
semaine c'était la séquence banlieu qui
devait Ré et là et là le lundi ou le
mardi le mardi matin le le
mardi Naël merzou qui est tué par un
policier à Nanterre avec les suites que
et et tout par voilà tout cette belle
cette cette réconciliation de Macron et
des banlieux bah ça tombe à l'eau et
avec la suite que vous connaissez
justement les les c'est c'est c'est ces
révoltes enfin qu'on a vu fin juin début
juillet
ell sont en rapport avec avec avec cette
politique ou c'est c'est quelque chose
qui alors moi ce que moi j'ai envie de
dire que cette question du rapport
politique de la ville et émeute moi le
rapport il est très direct mais il est
pas dans le sens qu'on entend beauou on
dit bah ça prouve que ça sert à rien la
politique de la ville regarder en tout
cas historiquement la seule ce qu'on
peut établir de façon très directe comme
entre les deux c'est que les émeutes ont
été le moteur de la politique de la
ville oui oui c'estàd elle est née à la
suite desmeutes elle a ses grands
changements sont à la suite des émeutes
les principau
program la constitue ont été lancé à la
suite desmeut et cet ensuite est-ce que
l'meut marquent l'échec de la politique
de la ville bah ça j'ai envie de vous
dire première chose c'est
que la politique de la ville n'a jamais
eu pour objectif de prévenir les émeutes
donc si on a une perspective évaluative
on peut pas dire deuxième chose c'est si
on voulait vraiment juger
scientifiquement du lien entre les deux
bah il faudrait pouvoir faire ce qu'on
appelle du contre factuel c'est-à-dire
dire que se serait-il passé s'il y avait
pas la politique de la ville et de ce
point de vue-là la séquence hmetière de
2023 elle est intéressante parce que et
ça là bon il y a des études qui se
lancent en ce moment et cetera mais déjà
sur la base des travaux de l'inspection
générale de de la police nationale et de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration et des premiers
recensements qu' de de de ce qui s'est
passé ce qu'on voit c'est que pour la
première fois dans les grandes vagues
émetières des émotes il y en a depuis
les années 80 mais elles sont souvent
localisées mais les grandes vagues
émetières ça a été 2005 un peu 91 11
aussi euh oui la plusente c'était 2005
ou oui oui mais là en 2023 bah écoutez
on a une bonne partie des quartiers où
il y a eu des émeutes qui étaient pas
visés par la politique de la ville n pas
touchéou et il y en a qui sont touchés
d'autres pas enfin c'est très compliqué
c'est et donc en tout cas pour moi il
est très difficile
de en tout cas de de de prendre l'émeute
comme la preuve ou quoi que de de
l'échec de de la politique de la de la
ville si on veut juger
aèr de faire et on fait des évaluations
sur ce qui s'est passé en 2023 des
recherches en cours dans mon laboratoire
on a lancé un gros programme de
recherche on fait du terrain on va
essayer de comprendre un peu plus et pas
parler simplement au doigts mouillés
voilà mais sur la base des travaux qu't
été fait en
2005 on peut quand même tirer quelques
fils quelques enseignements maintenant
faudra les vérifier là mais d'abord
pourquoi est-ce que les habitants ou les
ametiers résidents dans des quartiers
brûlent dans leur quartier brûlent
l'école
ou la prière réponse quand même c'est
que il y a pas un Act stratégique
politique en disant je vais aller sur
les symboles de la République c'est on
fait cramer ce qui est accessible est-ce
que et voilà et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
crame les les les bagnole bah parce
qu'elles sont là elles sont sur le
parking et parce que c'est il y a rien
de plus simple que de faire cramer une
bagnole je vais pas donner la recette
ici mais il y a rien de
plus alors que oui oui et puis je v pas
vous dire comment on fait mais vraiment
c'est très très simple faire brûler un
bâtiment public c'est déjà plus
compliqué faire brûler
maintenant les
émeutes plus on va faire les meutes dans
son quartier Mo on a de chance d'être
pris je vais
faire je sors du quartier oui oui je
connais moins l'espace les flics
connaissent mieux j'ai pas d'espace de
protection parce que dans le quartier je
connais les digicodes quand il y en a je
sais où monter me cacher quand je suis
coursé j'ai les copains qui connaissent
suffisamment le le système pour couper
les disjonctes et l'éclairage public
tombe et donc donc c'est quand même
lesmeutes elles se déroulent d'abord là
où on est où on a l'avantage de la
maîtrise du terrain euh d'accord ou
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans les
quartiers à
brûlerah pas grandchose il y a des
équipements publics parfois un petit
centre commercial et encore mais oui
mais sinon il y a massivement des écoles
une annexe de la mairie et donc je pense
que avant d'en faire des grandes
analyses théori
politiqu SBO de la République ils ont
voilà on a été cramé ce qu'il y avait
mais bon ensuite il peut y avoir d'
encore une fois ça je vous dis c'est
largement sur la base de ce qu'on a
analysé en 2005 allons voir si 2023
c'était la même chose je le pense mais
faudra vérifier faudra le vérifier un
mot sur l'exportation du conflit Israël
au palestinien dans les
quartiers il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont inquiets mais bah je pense que on
peut être inquiet sur l'exportation dans
les quartiers comme dans n'importe quel
quartier comme un peu partout comme
ailleurs c'est pas plus concerné enfin
bah qui quoi
là encore il faudrait faire des des
enquêtes plus plus pr plus plus précises
mais bon que qu'il ait une sensibilité
particulièrement forte à la cause
palestinienne auprès de populations
issues du du monde arabe c'est une
évidence
euh qu'il y ait une surconcentration de
ces
populations dans des quartiers visés par
la politique de la ville c'est un fait
pour autant est-ce que
les tensions qui peuvent
exister une traduction de ces tensions
spécifiquement dans ces quartiers
faudrait aller regarder dans les
quartiers où il y a une où il y a un
corore une coprésence particulière des
des populations juives et des
populations musulmane alors ce qui
existe encore à créteille ce qui existe
encore à
Sarcel à ma connaissance là depuis mais
j'ai pas regardé dans le détail il y a
j'ai pas vu apparaître de de faits
particuliers à Créteil ou à Sarcel alors
qu'il y a eu des des actes par exemple
antisémite par
oui ou donc faudrait voir moi j'ai
tendance à penser que on est dans
aujourd'hui dans des dans des tensions
qui traversent la société fr l'ensemble
des espaces maintenant il est possible
aussi qu' qu'il prennent une
manifestation particulière dans ces
quartiers à ce stade moi j'ai pas vu de
de de remonté particulière j'ai pas
entendu de remontter particulière
là-dessus mais que ce soit une crainte
un point d'attention évidemment un mot
sur ce qui enfin je simplifie un peu les
choses mais qui prétendent qu'on se
trompe peut-être en faisant en
sintéressant au quartier ces quartiers
de la politique de la ville disant
l'essentiel du problème c'est c'est ce
que dit Christophe guiloui hein dans la
France périphérique c'estàd celle dans
laquelle en gros enfin pour pour faire
simple les petits blancs ce sont sont
venu habiter parce c'était trop cher
d'habiter dans les centres-villes ouais
euh est-ce que il il faut opposer les
deux c'est deux choses différentes bah
en tout cas ce qui est très clair c'est
que il y a à la suite de Christophe
Guilly hein donc ce cette
c'est un peu plus suble mais bon euh un
certain nombre de forces politiques et
tout d'abord le rassembl rassemblement
national se sont saisis de cette analyse
pour mettre en opposition deux types de
territoires qui sont des territoires qui
sont quoi ou pour mettre en opposition
deux souffrances territoriales parce que
il y a des difficultés sociales une
concentration des difficultés sociales
très fortes dans les quartiers
périphériques des métropoles les qutiers
de la politique de la ville notamment
mais il y a aussi de grandes difficultés
sociales économiques et puis de des
difficultés liées à la disparition des
services publics et cetera dans les la
France des souspréfectures dans dans
cette France en
déclin
maintenant le le tour pour moi il il y a
un double tour de passe-p s opéré
d'abord opéré par Christophe Guil quand
il dit finalement les quartiers
périphériques des métropoles sont les
vrais privilégiés puisquil dit
finalement ces
quartiers il bénéficie d'une part de
l'accès à l'ensemble du dynamisme
économique des métropoles des offres
d'emploi et cetera et en plus il
bénéficie des milliards de la politique
de la ville donc en fait c'est les vrais
privilégiés il y a un sorte de tour de
passp de retournement les quartiers qui
ont le moins en fait ce serait eux les
vrais privilég et il occulte là-dedans
le fait que bah il y a pas de
discrimination positive c'est pas vrai
qu'on donne plus et il occulte le fait
que c'est pas parce que vous t vous
habitez à 10 bornes d'un endroit où vous
habitez à même à 500 m de la défense que
vous avez accès aux emplois de la
défensesument fron donc il y a cette
première chose première et puis la
deuxième chose c'est le l'opposition qui
qui l'a organisé et qui a été
instrumentalisé repris politiquement par
Marine Le Pen qui consiste à dire mais
quand vous habitez dans le péri urbain
ou dans une petite ville en déclin en
fait vous voyez la disparition des
emplois la disparition des services
publics mais c'est la faute à la
politique de la ville c'est parce qu'on
met des milliards pour les quartiers que
vous AZ rien voilà et c'est cette mise
en opposition qui est qui est très très
très très problématique alors même que
bah il y a un certain nombre de
difficultés qu'on retrouve dans ces
différents types d'espac les territoires
ruraux en déprises le péri urbain les
territoires ultramarins qui connaissent
de grandes difficultés et les quartiers
pauvres des des métropoles quand on
regarde il y a un certain nombre de
problématiques qui sont communes
euh et que il y a sans doute voilà il y
a des ensuite il y a des clivages
politiques il y a des stratégies
partisanes politiques qui cherchent à
organiser des oppositions et puis en
face il y a aussi d'autres stratégies
politiques en face qui sont proposées
qui consistent à faire l'inverse à
essayer d'organiser l'articulation le
lien si vous regardez la thèse de du
livre qui a eu beaucoup de succès de
Thomas picketti et KAG là-dessus ça cons
dire recréons l'alliance des couches
populaires qu'ell soi rural et voilà
donc là on on rentre dans un chan de la
lutte politique plutôt lutte politique
observation politique un un dernier mot
pour finir c'est vrai que
euh vous avez raison vous l'aviez dit
tout à l'heure on on sttigmatise souvent
les les les quartiers il y a aussi des
choses formidables qui s passent il y a
des gens qui réussissent il y a des il y
a des politiques et des associations qui
se battent qui font des des des actions
formidables
euh est-ce que le le au fond le discours
qu'on tient sur ces quartiers est
important même vis-à-vis des gens qui y
habitent bien sûr moi il me semble
semble que c'est c'est c'est déterminant
que au-delà de la la la réponse sociale
urbaine
économique du fait que bah dans un
contexte d'augmentation forte de la
pauvreté bah il y a des vraies
difficultés sociales et qui il faut
trouver des moyens pour que bah des gens
puissent manger vivent dignement et
cetera mais la dignité c'est aussi une
dignité symbolique et de la
reconnaissance et quand on parle des
quartiers de manière générale de façon
extrêmement stigmatisante délinquant
drogue communautarisme islamisme
quartier de la République et
cetera ce qui peut par ailleurs prendre
moi je suis pas en train de de dire
bisou nours tout va bien dans les
quartiers et C non il y a des vrais
problèmes des problèmes qui affectent
les populations ces quartier mais quand
quand on fait des coups de zoom
exclusivement là-dessus et qu'on a
construit une sorte de catégorie
générale les quartiers vous faites un
reportage sur telle cité de de scè
saintis où il y a eu tel problème ou le
qu nord de Marseille ou de nî ou il y a
eu et que vous les médias ont tendance
souvent à monter en généralité dire bah
c'est pas un truc qui s'est passé à à
valde Gour à Nim ou quartier nord de
Marseille mais c'est les quartiers bah
ça rejaillit sur l'image de tout le
monde où qu'on soit euh et euh quand on
parle de vous avez le sentiment qu'on ne
parle de vous que de façon négative de
façon stigmatisante bah c'est un
problème de de dignité c'est un problème
aussi de sentiment d'appartenance
nationale et on dit vous des gens vous
êtes communautarist entre soi mais qu'on
a le sentiment d'être en permanence
suspecté de d'être hors de d'être mis à
l'écart ça ça produit toute une série
d'effets et puis cette construction de
représentation un peu généralisée ça
alimente aussi toute une série de
mécanismes de discrimination qui font
que bah des employeurs des gens qui
peuvent être pas racistes du tout vont
avoir tendance à à laisser de côté
certains CV parce qu'on parce que quand
même on sait pas parce que on peut avoir
des craintes donc oui oui je crois que
la la la présentation de de de ces
quartiers fait partie du problème et
fait partie sans doute de la solution
merci c'est merci à vous merci beaucoup
rodstein pour cet éclairage quant à nous
ben on se retrouve très bientôt pour un
nouveau numéro de tribune qui sera
d'ailleurs toujours consacré à la
politique de la
ville